making drawings on land on quite a large
scale is something people do for
thousands of years
[Music]
i'm simon beck
and i make drawings in the snow
[Music]
it started as a bit of fun
but gradually he's taken over my life
a ballpark estimate of footsteps
about 5 000 steps in an hour
a big drawing
two hours measuring eight hours work
you're looking at forty thousand steps
[Music]
i started doing it as an easier
alternative to hiking at the mountain
when i wanted an exercise
you're starting with a
drawer on a piece of paper
or else to draw it in your mind
just treating it like an orienteering
map
you're just going a certain distance in
a certain direction
to determine distances by counting bases
it's a very physical exercise it's
equivalent to a long days walking in the
hills when you make one of these big
drawings
[Music]
i'm just about the only person in the
world doing anything like it
[Music]
this colorful spot has a dark past
las pamitas was once a dangerous place
with clashes between rival gangs
but the city government launched and
funded a project called pachuca paints
itself to turn the community around
[Music]
the painting itself involved
participation from all of the households
[Music]
they painted over 200 houses using 5 000
gallons of paint
[Music]
these individually painted houses
combine to make one beautiful rainbow
design
inspired by pachuca's nickname la baya
rosa or the beautiful breezy city
the aim of the project was to bring a
sense of liveliness and livability back
to the city
the ministry of planning and evaluation
of the city of pachuca has noted that
the crime rate in the city has decreased
since the mural was painted
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
well i love painting a mask because it
gets me out in weather like this
it's pretty awesome to come into a
resort and look up and see mind map
[Music]
i'm james nehes and i've painted ski
maps of some of the biggest resorts
around the world
i painted 194
different maps
this is north star out of lake tahoe new
mexico ski area we have snow basin here
utah
this is an image that skiers see they
judge the mountain by the trail map you
want to portray the mountain as
beautiful as it is
i was a advertising agency man for a
while
in 1987 i painted my first trail map
yeah they used my map
i loved it right away i could paint and
do a little travel and learn how to ski
whenever i get a call from a resort
first thing that i'll do is scoop out
the mountain and see what i've got to
work with
i work heavily from aerial photography
where i'll go up in a plane and take a
paint across the whole mountain in a
shot
from this i take it back to the studio
and i get on my computer and select the
ones that i want to work from print them
out and then i reference all the
material that i can get and start my
sketch
what i will have to do is manipulate the
different elements of the mountain and
get it on a single plane of paper on a
single page
what i like to do is show the skier what
he's skiing through they help the skier
identify where he is on the mountain
for a large ski resort it'll take me
three weeks of painting but that doesn't
include all your prep work so
realistically it'll take me three months
do i have a favorite mountain wow
i've done a lot of them and a lot of
really exciting mountains
there's a lot of things that i love
about doing this job i get to fly in
some of the most beautiful spots in the
world
i'm going to keep doing this as long as
i can
[Music]
i just want to start and go and go and
go
the longest amount of time that i can
draw
before the tide comes in washes
everything away
my name is jim donovan i draw in the
sand
to draw on the sand it's a balance
between a mental game and a
physical they're both equally important
i started drawing in the sand
a little more than 20 years ago
i was walking along the beach one day it
just came to me to use it as a canvas
i just put my finger in the sand and
made a
giant fish
i became really really obsessed with it
i left behind the world both of surfing
and the job as a chef and i just put
everything into drawing in the sand
there was almost no one in the whole
world that did this kind of thing
i've drawn in sand around the world
australia uruguay argentina chile russia
i mean occasionally it's a mission but
we're also in places where oh there's a
nice patch of sand i think i'll go do
something there
the one that was 10 miles in
circumference in the desert on dry lake
is the guinness world record largest
heart
i walked as much as 30 miles in one day
which means about seven or eight hours
of walking
i like the stick probably the best
because i like to come down to the beach
with nothing
the tools are sitting there on the beach
sticks to choose from and i'll
do my composition
do a nice big drawing and then i'll
throw the stick away i'm down with
nothing and leave with nothing for me
that's the most fulfilling choice of how
to do it
drawing the sand is the ultimate of in
the moment and i want to finish when the
tide is about to destroy the drawing
this is going to change every day
anything i do down there is going to be
gone and every time i'm going to have a
big huge place
to try something new
[Music]
you